hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm Grantland waifu and today I
am all about lights camera and action my
fellow nerds I have a speech to make
it's very important and I'm glad you've
all come together to hear me discuss
tracker tracker episodes 34 and 35 but
this is an important message just for
you do you ever feel like there's a
channel owner telling you that you can't
use particular words to carry across
your needs and thoughts because they
have personally become sick of your
preferred choice of clothing and the
comedic stick that goes along with it do
you sometimes wish you could take a
popular spinning toy from a certain
vacuum face strange man with one metal
leg and flick it at said channel owners
nose watching it bounce off into the
distance do you ever consider the fact
that said channel owner keeps using
photographs of you to carry across ideas
when they could make up entire audiences
of an animated version of your face do
you ever decide on a whim to like or
dislike video is edited by this channel
runner based on descriptions that very
obviously allude to previous videos of
well-known shows that are about tracking
down something do you really like cats
me neither
let's discuss Hunter hunter episodes 34
and 35 just so you're aware this video
contains big old spoilers big spoilers
swinging spoilers episode 34 is all
about flexing some serious muscle I
enjoys just I enjoyed oh my I enjoyed
having a combat Laden fight and you know
what compared to shows like Dragon Ball
and well mostly Dragon Ball it's nice to
have a fight that resolves in one
episode normally but more than that we
had gone and killed while showing how
they learn and change their behavior to
be a psychopathic as they can be
starting the episode with the reminder
that Kiawah threat and seducer was a
fantastic energy balance to bring us
into a fight that was in theory supposed
to be very controlled the fact that
sudah so warned the other two that
kilowatt and gone were not to be trifled
with and simply left town and really
should have warned them we've had
several situations at this point where
people have ignored the warnings of
those who have had experiences with our
main psychopaths and they always fail to
learn a few episodes ago I think I
suggested that altering their name
would mean they'd constantly come up
against this turns out they will always
come up against this the only one who
doesn't seem to underestimate them as
his soca but we'll get to him later and
probably later again given the end of
this episode it seemed really cute just
as a note for sudah so for all his
ability to get to the 200th floor was
wearing just a slingback bum bag or
fanny pack they're the same thing
depending on your global location don't
at me I have no idea why I'm noticing
clothes so much recently but maybe we
should have a fashion show in the end
yes I love the scene between the real
veldt
Giro and kilwa yet it is certain Juna
say Kwame Elan fair blue to the episode
these villains who have seemed very
dangerous and creepy just a few episodes
ago very quickly became entirely
harmless the energy shift was sudden and
very cleverly done frankly it helped us
as an audience come to terms with where
quinoa and gone were in terms of power
that he could entirely hide his name
from them something he had been unable
to do just a few days ago with Castro
thinking about these particular villains
there's something I'd like to raise I'm
not sure whether the fact that each of
these bad guys having a disability is a
good thing or a bad thing
I love that the representation is
present and I love that it's so
normalized sodaw so having no arm you
know having one leg creo vault in a real
vault in a chair on seriously powered
caterpillars I'd love to hear from
people in these groups because this to
me feels like one of those things that
could swing either way the power of
these characters is evident they only
come to us at the 200th floor they're
very powerful and they'd be gone they're
very clearly talented and capable even
if they are bad but the fact that
they're bad and to be defeated makes my
head tilt slightly to go a little
further into God being his own
psychopathic self did he have to smash
keido's leg it's not the storytelling
I'm struggling with him it's fantastic
how clear it is that our main characters
are awful that they'll do anything to
accomplish their goal and yes I know
that this is his way of getting payback
for their earlier deception but this
behavior in particular if we were
playing one of my nerd games yes I play
Dungeons and Dragons I'd have said this
was very clearly an evil act at the
point where he was crushing a leg he
could have knocked out Dido he could
have done any number of things that
didn't mean essentially snapping the
vacuum faced man's only prosthetic leg
in
at this juncture I need to say that I
have discussed this episode with this
guy
and he says that the whole world is full
of evil people and the people like my
cutie pies ooh she is the aberration
because he's one of the only good ones
okay sure but here's where we then say
what are the levels of evil if we assume
the actors evil and he's doing it solely
for payback then he's no better than
those he's fighting he's certainly no
better that or pure than karappa Kahoot
wants to kill those who destroyed his
entire people Leigh audio is suddenly in
the same league as sushi as the only
person whose purpose is to help where is
Leigh audio at the moment is he just
taking exams anyway to cut a long story
short Dawn's behavior is pretty awful
and his faking out of Rio volt is
equally awful but kind of funny since
real welders actively tried to kill
kilwa with them so hey that's fun now to
hopefully see how GaN goes fighting his
hunter pursuer
Hisoka his Sokka yes let's discuss
episode 35 okay but why does it feel
like I didn't know GaN surname before
now and why does it feel as though his
name is really important I'm sure it'll
come to me and I'm sure Liam is putting
some kind of spoiler up on the screen
about now we all know I don't actually
watch these I just do the writing and
recording so you'll probably know we
know his dad is an important hunter and
we know he entered the exam to learn why
his dad left and I'm sure there is a lot
of information that has been given to us
fairly piecemeal but it's been a long
week and I'm tired so help me out but
actually don't I don't want spoilers not
really and actually apparently rather
struggle in other news congratulations
to GaN for leveling up yay
he finally finished the real exam which
Leigh audio has not apparently I wonder
how and when Leigh audio will learn how
to use nen I'm really glad we could go
back to arc 1 and take a quick look at
how everyone's going there was something
very nostalgic about being able to see
old if not friends then competitors and
how they were going kill was blush when
he was told to apply for the hunter exam
again totally gave away his acceptance
of compliments and showed just how much
he actually trusts and respects wing who
it turns out must be a hunter in his own
right
the fact that Notaro is the head of the
arena is delicious music to my ears
I loved the other two were as excited in
inverted commas by the prospect as I was
and it makes me really hope that frankly
they get to fight him to go on got
Notaro to use both hands when they first
met i wonder what would happen now
I imagine if they had been able to take
that basketball it would have required
men and would have meant they were
indeed immediately qualified to be
hunters which is an interesting bit of
information zoo she my baby zoo she just
needs more confidence if he hadn't met
gone and quinoa he would have so much
more confidence than he has now well
maybe not but I like to think so he's
going to make a wonderful hunter one day
my boy I'm so proud of him stay pure
sushi and come back as the protagonist
of your own series or maybe the
protagonist of this one cuz you know
kill one go on a kind of antagonists
let's be honest please come back between
sushi being cut up about having to train
for another four weeks and the smooth
jazz of that scene with the soft colors
of a sunset I cried in that moment
anyone who knows me knows I cry at great
chord changes in music so it's not that
big a deal but for me to cry it means
the stakes were high the musical tone
one point the voice acting was great and
well-timed and the art matched the
moment I don't cry for just anything I
cry because what I saw was satisfying
that scene was simply satisfying there
were a lot of beautiful moments that hit
well in this episode and it was
something I really appreciated since
we've been through some high-octane but
not as deep episodes recently in fact a
discussion about lighting and sound in
this episode is in order
the silent moments once we began to head
into the fight between his Sokka and
gone or a wonderful juxtaposition the
creep factor was high as it looked in
each of those cuts as though his Sokka
was watching gone prepare from that
moment however it was great because we
as an audience were removed from gone
and his sokka's minds and placed into a
seat in the stadium the lights going out
were as much for us and the haze and
light and smoke and commercial nature of
that scene was also a great counterpoint
to the scene before of Zushi and chicken
wing in many ways this episode is one of
my favorites and not only because it's a
Hisoka episode I've said that however
let's dive into that I did my best to
discuss the rest of the episode first
because it was really beautiful but come
on we know who the main event is he
knows who he is too and he didn't mind
showing his torch to point down he owes
the main event I really should have
expected the Schwing of his song
partially because he's a Sokka and this
is what we've been gearing up to since
we met him
and partially because we had that slow
pan up to his face that put him into one
of his sexy time modes folks I don't
know how to describe this in ways that
remain family-friendly but it's pretty
clear at this point that hunter hunter
is not actually a family-friendly show
if my parents had realized how
suggestive this show was I would never
have been able to watch it as a child
that said I got to the end of the South
Park movie by myself before they
realized just what the cartoons were
singing about so the odd thing about the
sexy scenes that occurred with Hisoka is
that the slow pan up matched perfectly
to create innuendo which was then
immediately dropped for out un dome as
we had that bright mole the hip flexing
swing Hisoka was having a great time I'm
amazed he even had the presence of mind
to stop gone from fighting that said he
is an important thing about Hisoka that
maybe we haven't discussed properly he
seems like a pedophile right he does I
mean I think he does psychologically
though I think he's getting his Schwing
on because he enjoys seeing the
development of potential more than he
likes gone because he's a boy I may be
entirely wrong and frankly I'm so loose
on this that maybe I am wrong but I
still have some hope so I'll cling to
that the way Liam clings to the hope I
won't use the word or because they're
easy laughs the fight hilarious since I
mentioned Dragon Ball in the first half
of this we end up in a dragon ball like
fight sequence I would even argue that
maybe that's where the inspiration for
the sequence came from artistically but
then it does something very hunter
hunter that sets it apart very clearly
Gahan realizes he needs to change his
tactic to beat his opponent this is
really important because in Dragon Ball
the answer to being unable to beat an
opponent is to get stronger but that's
not what we do here it's not what
happens it's fantastic for that rather
than putting us into God's mind we
remain in the audience with Kiowa kill
our reason through the fight and realize
right at the last moment that Gahan has
had the same thought process and follows
it to a conclusion that is simply
wonderful Gahan hits and so he can
return his sokka's number tag he doesn't
need to beat his Sokka he's done what he
aimed to do it's all about whether he
will do his wing told him and not overdo
it and isn't that thought satisfying
but not as satisfying is that
time-honored phrase that's it for me
like share subscribe click a thing here
click your thing them join the discord
server I hear things happen there
dedicate random pieces of your body to
me I appreciate all the noms I can get
and name a delicious dinner that Liam
can make to feed me in the comments
below see you next time